um there are a number of uh again free
licenses
especially if you are from nepe so how
do you know if you're a part of nepy
there's a website
nappy.org
where you can see the map and all of the
23 idea states are listed on there if
you're from one of the academic
institutions in one of those idea states
you're most likely a part of nepi what
you need to check is whether that
institution is listed
because
nepe is an organization that brings
together pais
funded through the
nih idea institution development award
so uh if you receive this information
from your um
uh core
you probably have access uh to those
free licenses
okay so what i will try to do in the
next few minutes is briefly explain
how this training is going to be
different from what most of you are
probably used to when
it comes to
online coursework like coursera
what are the specific benefits of taking
this training and how will you be able
to use some of the skills or resources
that you will
gain access to throughout the summer
so
first of all as already mentioned by
jabs in the beginning
we try to assemble training materials a
number of data analysis tools curated
project data sets so data sets that are
ready for analysis and interactive
sessions that some of them are going to
be available as recorded sessions or if
you're available during that time you
can join them live
and this is to make bioinformatics more
project based or
oriented around case studies
so
bioinformatics is a very broad
uh and dynamic field there's a lot of
new things that come up all the time
and so it's very difficult to
imagine someone kind of comprehensively
understanding bioinformatics is in only
three months and so that's why instead
of offering to kind of train you and
give you everything you need to know
bioinformatics we're saying this is
oriented around case studies how is
bioinformatics used in cancer studies
specifically using transcriptomic data
or how is bioinformatics used in the
study of infectious diseases for example
if we want to understand genomic and
transcriptomic data to study the
pathogen and to understand the host
responses right so those are the case
studies
for um again those of you that
kind of work already on some of those
similar projects this is the opportunity
to take your project and just analyze
that data as you go along
and that means that we're going to be
dealing with a diverse group of
individuals that some are faculty
very independent driven by maybe
research objectives and questions that
they would like to get answered as well
as some undergraduate students that
might be new to all of this and are just
trying to get started
and so that's why we're going to be
offering
a number of these different resources so
that you can explore the ones that you
need
on your own time but also have access to
lectures and
mentors that can actually help you and
guide you and help you overcome
technical issues that you might face
so what we've done over the past few
years is we have collected industry
and academia lectures from a number of
organizations including uh different
nepe associated organizations and kind
of prepared a basic package and that
basic package includes genomics
transcriptomics metagenomics epigenomics
introduction to data science and
kind of a collection of different
project examples
in addition to that we understand that a
lot of people might come from a biology
background and they might not be
prepared for the technical demands of
both learning how to program a specific
analysis
as well as setting up that analysis to
run
on a specific infrastructure like your
own laptop or maybe your core
high performance computer or something
like that and so because of that this
program comes with another important
resource called the t bioinfo
analytical platform now the platform
offers a semi-guided experience where
you have a number of predefined paths
that connect independent scripts into a
pipeline
and they come with a lot of
computational resources for example
every account will come with five
terabytes of storage
you can also at the end request for that
particular pipeline to be submitted into
a list of containerized pipelines that
you could deploy elsewhere
and most importantly you get a lot of
support so if you want to really
understand how it works what are the
parameters how do you change them how do
you run it for this type of data or that
type of data this is what the programs
are going to be about it is to provide
you with that kind of technical support
for example
how does this achieve learning goals
that we
are expecting to kind of arrive at after
this program
in many cases you are probably familiar
with
figures figures that represent analysis
like
statistical analysis maybe principal
component analysis or maybe differential
gene expression or you might be familiar
with
mapping and visualization of map breeds
on a reference genome so the platform
will combine those kinds of analyses
into a
an experience where
every point in that process will be
color coded and will come with an
explanation so that you can understand
what you are doing
change parameters if need be and also
remember how did you achieve a specific
result so makes that analysis
reproducible
now
in the program we will use both the
platform and then we will look at what
do some of these individual buttons do
how do they actually take in some data
that was already prepared for that stage
what type of data do they produce
what does that data look like and what
does the
analysis try to do how does it work
and so because we have multiple
comparison in each comparisons in each
logical step you will see how by looking
at the analogous analysis
uh that are available what are the
differences and how might you choose the
right type of analysis for your specific
goal
i'm going to pause here because i have a
couple of questions i'd like to answer
so uh question number one from analia if
you are not a part of any of the
fundamental programs how do you register
i will share again links where you can
purchase the program independently or
you can go to your pi or to your
university and say i would like to take
this training over the summer and a lot
of cases they will uh you know offer to
pay for that or maybe support you
partially
and the second question from ashley was
about this recording being available yes
this recording will be available after
the webinar and also it's going to be on
our
youtube channel
[Music]
so as i mentioned beyond this logic it's
also important to at least understand
how code works and what are some of
those steps that you can take to get
started with coding in r and python two
two of the most popular uh languages in
scientific computing
so
what we will do is we will actually
use several of the examples
after the big data is processed and
we've kind of distilled it to structured
data or tables we will look at what is
the context so how do we ask questions
about a particular data
then what is the logic how do we
actually understand the steps to arrive
at a particular result then we will try
to practice and then hopefully that will
prepare you to be completely independent
both relying on big data analysis tools
which you will find many of those are
available today but also if you would
like to take your analysis further and
kind of take a look at um you know
becoming more independent and being able
to write such uh analyses yourself
so now let me talk briefly about um
three of the programs uh so the first
one i'll talk about is biomedical data
analysis using rn python
this is a program designed for those who
are interested to learn how to write
code
so in many cases you will have a
particular
type of data that is already structured
and
for that structured data you either want
to
perform a statistical analysis
exploratory analysis maybe you would
like to
also use machine learning so that is
what this program is going to cover
first of all for those of you that are
not familiar with r and python at all
there's a way to get started right and
so what we've done on the portal is
we've taken some of the basic principles
like dealing with objects loading data
into
an environment where you can analyze
data
looking at specific
data sets and understanding structures
like matrices data frames etc so those
are the things that are going to be
covered in that introductory course and
that is available completely for free if
you haven't started with coding we
highly recommend it will help you
kind of extract meaningful insights out
of complex data visualize and present
them but beyond that we're also going to
go into
kind of a
high level overview of what data science
is and how is it applied specifically to
biomedical projects and here we will
have two tracks one is bioml and r and
biomel in python you can choose each
either one
and you will see
how these are used today when analyzing
complex data but also you will be
exposed to a number of standard or what
we call conventional machine learning
tools methods that are going to be very
helpful to deal with noisy data and data
that contains a lot of variability for
example patient data that contains a lot
of variability
so here is a brief overview of the
topics that we will cover
we'll talk about data wrangling how to
load transform and explore a data set
we'll talk about machine learning and
statistics what is the difference how do
they kind of compare to each other and
why high throughput data presents some
additional challenges for these methods
what is the general kind of
distinction between unsupervised and
supervised types of analysis
how can we use machine learning for data
visualization
then we'll talk
exclusively about clustering and another
session about classification
we'll talk a lot about how these methods
not only what types of methods there are
but how are they used in example
projects and we'll try to address some
biological questions that you might have
so for example
what is the bigger difference between
different tissues or is it between
normal and cancer tissue right so we'll
kind of use those methods to try to
connect it back to the types of
questions that you might have then we'll
talk about feature selection and
signature patterns how we can define a
particular signature pattern for example
a marker and then how can we understand
what that marker actually represents
what feature is it connected to
we'll talk about regression and
generalized linear models and deep
learning um and how deep learning is
used so all of these are going to be
covered
in a live session so kind of like what
we're doing today
there will be someone speaking there
will be questions questions will be
answered there will be some exercises
but then you will also have a number of
examples and additional projects that
you can practice independently
so what is that going to look like uh
here's an example of a course this is a
course on pca so how do you actually
produce a plot a three-dimensional or a
two-dimensional scatter plot to
understand variance in your data you go
through
first of all uh understanding the
problem you know why are you using pca
in this case then you will learn the
syntax of the code so how can code be
written to actually perform this kind of
analysis then you will be given that
code that you can run
and you will be able to modify outputs
so in one case you might produce a table
and another one you might produce a
visual output etc
then you'll be able to play around with
that code and know that you can modify
settings then this is very important
because in so many cases once you know
that there's a library that you can use
you just need to modify it to apply it
to your data and then make it do what
you would like it to do
it is a very liberating experience and
you can start going through
a lot of examples that people have
posted online and read that code
understanding what it was doing and know
how to modify it to apply it to your
problem
and then finally once you go through
several examples like that you will be
given some
challenges
and those challenges will come as an
interactive notebook and they will
essentially be an assignment so you will
start with some beginning for example
you've learned the syntax you've applied
it to a particular data then the coding
challenge will say okay write this code
uh
maybe there's a missing portion or maybe
write it from scratch or maybe even
apply it to a number of different
examples that are not trivial
they will need some thinking to overcome
some issues that you will have
and again as a result you will have an
interactive notebook that interactive
notebook will be shared with your mentor
and your mentor will be able to suggest
some uh maybe technical issues how to
overcome them or maybe how to use other
types of methods for
whatever
challenge you are facing
now importantly we will look at some of
the ways that these methods actually
work and what needs to be done with
those methods to overcome common
challenges like missing data
maybe unbalanced classes will talk a lot
about evaluating the accuracy and
precision
how to trust your model how to deploy
your model after you've trained it all
of those kinds of questions is something
that we will focus on and kind of see
real world examples so
what are the outcomes of such a program
the outcomes of such a program first of
all
some technical skills and kind of
reading papers looking at the methods
and knowing what they mean but also
putting them into a logical scheme so
that you can
kind of go from experimental design and
all the way to interpretation
through the lens of the analysis process
how the data is prepared for analysis
how is it explored to eliminate maybe
artifacts batches than issues with the
data how do they then perform actual
data analysis choosing between maybe a
model
that is statistical or maybe a machine
learning model and then how to produce
inference something that you can
interpret either in the context of that
particular experiment or something more
generalizable something that you could
kind of build upon to understand
something about the general population
so again what we will do is we will use
some case studies
and all of these cases are going to rely
on omics data so we will look at
diagnostics and cancer biology single
cell and tissue composition and we'll
also look at microbiome and infection
and you'll be able to choose
a number of curated data sets that will
be provided to you to kind of play
around with and develop a
project of your own at the end of this
course at the end of this training
program
so again if you have any questions about
this particular program any of the
topics that i just mentioned please add
them to the chat box i'd be happy to
answer any of those questions
and i'll just
give a moment here if anyone has any
questions
okay so again how do you register for
this particular program
the way you register is dependent on
which organization you're from so you
could be from three organizations
lsu school of veterinary medicine
uh
the second organization is lbrn
louisiana biomedical research network
and the third organization is
the
national association of idea principal
investigators so based on which
organization you're from
if you were not present in the beginning
of the webinar or kind of went through
all the different options how to
register but you definitely have to
create an account on the learn portal
and once you do please email us and you
can email to a number of emails here
so for hana shared her email or you can
simply reach out to
this email right here
we'll be able to direct you on your next
steps and even have a call to discuss
your specific questions
okay so uh raquel is asking when the
course will start and end so this is a
summer program and so it's going to
start um
15th all the way until august 31st and
extend it until september 15th so you
will have a full three months to work
through all of these different things
there's going to be a defined schedule
of live sessions but all the live
sessions are going to be recorded and
all of them will be shared on the
program page and i will go over the
program page at the end of this present